sí pues la verdad es que una gran
mayoría de los países europeos estaba a
favor de esta reducción del 55 por
ciento al menos de los gases
contaminantes por aquí el hueso duro de
roer era polonia un país especialmente
muy muy dependiente del carbón de hecho
es un país que depende mucho de esta del
carbón y por lo tanto el polonia ha sido
la que ha hecho trasnochar a los colegas
europeos porque quería arrancar
realmente un compromiso de que habrá
suficientes fondos europeos para todos
los países para hacer frente a esta
transición ecológica porque sobre todo
también hay muchos puestos de trabajo en
juego por otra parte también se asegura
que el gas y también las centrales
nucleares se podrían seguir utilizando
algo muy importante para países como por
ejemplo para francia sobre la cuestión
de los presupuestos polonia también era
uno de los países que bloqueaba el
acuerdo junto con hungría finalmente en
los líderes europeos que habían aprobado
que a partir de ahora todos los fondos
europeos tienen que se puedan distribuir
en los países europeos tienen que
asegurarse que realmente van a respetar
derecho hungría y polonia han levantado
su veto porque consideraban que podrían
ser injustamente tratados los líderes
europeos han asegurado que se estudiará
de forma objetiva y además siempre
podrán acudir a la justicia europea si
hay duda